broadcast channels cable networks and
streaming services have unveiled their
next wave of new and returning shows and
there's a lot to look forward to but not
every series can be a hit well your new
favorite guilty pleasure thrive or will
it even survive the year here's a look
at some new TV shows that probably won't
survive 2018 living biblically in 2007
humorist AJ Jacobs made waves with his
book my year of living biblically and
which he tried to live every aspect of
his life according to the rules set
forth in the Bible now the book has been
adopted as a gimmicky sitcom Junior
Ferguson hot off of the quickly
cancelled sitcom the real O'Neal's
plays chip curry a guide to crossroads
in his life after the death of a friend
and with a baby on the way he freaks out
an OPS to live you know biblically it
could be funny but for whom living
biblically risked offending true
believers but the subject matter could
also easily alienate some religious
viewers that's a tough balancing act so
something will have to give so when God
says do not worship false idols he's
talking about Beyonce rise an idealistic
teacher at a cash-strapped school is
determined to put on a musical and show
his students the power of their dreams
it expected rise to be inspiring instead
it's oddly depressing despite featuring
How I Met Your mother's Josh Radnor and
boasting a bunch of supposedly uplifting
musical numbers Glee proved that
something like rise could be good but so
far it's too earnest for its own good
unless it learns how to lighten up rise
may soon fall this isn't just about your
vision mr. massive these are people's
lives you're dealing with American Idol
it was once the most popular TV show in
the world but just two short years ago
fans have become so burned out on
American Idol and it was unceremoniously
dumped by Fox now it's back on ABC but
in a world dominated by NBC's The Voice
the fans even want more American Idol
sure it boasts Katy Perry at the head of
a new lineup of judges but it also
features a return of embattled hos to
Ryan Seacrest who has become something
of a Hollywood pariah after accusations
of harassment surfaced he was later
cleared by a network investigation but
just like nobody was asking for the show
to return nobody was asking for Seacrest
to return either it's just not a good
way to start what was bound to be an
uphill climb
for American Idol anyway Titans there
have been a lot faced around Teen Titans
a scrappy DC Comics property about The
Adventures of a squad of young
superheroes and erstwhile sidekicks
which at various times has included
characters like Robin Kid Flash
Aqualad Raven and Starfire and while the
animated versions of Teen Titans have
been popular over the years the new
live-action titans has had a very
troubled development TNT announced the
show in 2014 but the pilot never
materialized instead the team behind the
popular line of DC shows on the CW
announced a new version in 2017 but it's
not going to be on the CW instead -
debuting at an undetermined date on DC's
upcoming streaming service which doesn't
actually exist yet it's gonna take some
real super heroics to save this one
Heather's a TV series is almost
certainly doomed to fail if it never
actually airs right the Paramount
network's
TV adaptation of the 1988 high-school
black comedy Heather's is looking like
it could enter the rare gallery of shows
canceled before they broadcast a single
episode scheduled to debut in early
March Heather's was delayed indefinitely
due to the parkland Florida school
shooting taking Heather's off the table
as a move made out of good taste like
it's 1988 cold classic source material
it's a story about getting back a
bully's through school violence
Daniel daddario of time said the series
makes broad and sloppy comedy out of the
idea of teens dying by their own hand or
are the hands of other teens
it's seemingly designed to provoke and
to offend that might have worked 30
years ago but it doesn't work now here
and now created by Alan Ball here and
now combines a complicated family
dynamics and awareness of his series six
feet under with a kooky supernaturalism
of his other series True Blood the
result is less than the sum of its parts
with Tim Robbins and Holly Hunter
playing parents to an international
conglomeration of adopted children
allowing them to have a naturally
important conversations about the issues
of our time multiple characters also
have weird prophetic dreams and spooky
hallucinations numerology is an
important plot device and Robin's
character is anxious about aging and is
also having an affair in other words
here and now tries to be too many things
to too many people and as a result
actually does nothing for anybody
ratings have been terrible and
deception has been even worse suggesting
here and now may soon be dead and gone
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]